da sind wir wieder meine damen und
herren zurück aus der winterpause und
mittendrin in der fetten omikron welle
vierstellige instanzen die einschläge
kommen immer näher und überall fällt
personal aus natürlich auch hier beim
fernsehen wir sind schon froh wenn wir
überhaupt noch eine notbesetzung
zusammenkriegen in der regie zum
beispiel wird gerade eine neue kollegin
eingearbeitet natürlich erstmal nur als
mini job aber macht sie gut und an
camera 3 ist heute der oscar
eingesprungen der arbeitet normalerweise
beim heute journal ja die pandemie ist
ganz offensichtlich in einer neuen phase
angekommen und die strategie dazu sieht
so aus
wir kapitulieren
omikron glückwunsch du hast gewonnen'
das virus rauscht voll durch und andere
länder wie zum beispiel spanien die ihn
stehen dienstes dazu dass sie durch
rauschen lassen bei uns würde es einfach
nicht ausgesprochen karl lauterbach sagt
zwar durch solchen sei eine unethische
wette dabei machen wir genau das zb in
schulen und kitas was ist das denn für
eine kommunikation leute sagt doch den
bürgern einfach ehrlich das mensch oscar
schaffe
dakota
gleichzeitig stagniert ausgerechnet
jetzt die deutsche impfquote aber nicht
mehr lange freunde nicht mehr lange denn
unser kanzler hat längst das ultimative
pr as im ärmel diese unfassbar coole
plakat kampagne mit dem slogan im wild
das ist nur ein ganz kleiner auszug von
dem was wir uns vorgenommen haben es
kommen noch viele viele andere dazu vom
radio spot zur benutzung der
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten die sich mit
social media verbinden wow impfen hilft
da grübelt eine agentur monatelang für
eine kampagne die übrigens kein witz 60
millionen euro kostet und endet bei
impfen hilft unfalls sie zuhause sich
wundern warum sie bei dem plakat so
einen latenten harndrang kriegen die
farben erinnern stark an den sanifair
bon
ist leider zu spät aufgefallen blöd
impfen hilft aber wer weiß vielleicht
bringt genau der slogan ja die wende
warte mal impfen hilft ach so manfred
wusstest du dass ihm von
allen die ich liebe klar auch allen juli
besteht doch da ich eh sofort zum
impfzentrum nämlich auch gott sei dank
haben wir das schild gelesen ja
ein extrem fantasielose plakat wie
unkreativ kann man eigentlich sein wenn
überhaupt dann impfen hätte geholfen
könnt ihr gern verwenden schickt mir
einfach 60 millionen 60 wissen sie wie
viele pcr tests man davon kaufen könnte
weil deutschland seine test strategie
samt den laboren hauptsächlich auf
schnelltests ausgelegt hat fehlen jetzt
wieder ohne ende pcr tests und wenn man
dann noch weiß dass gesundheitsämter die
kontakt nach verfolgung aufgeben sind
die deutschen corona zahlen ab jetzt
quasi ja offiziell geraten geraten ja
natürlich sie bleiben aber grundlage von
politik wir bürger sollen selber unsere
kontakte informieren hey
warum machen wir nicht einfach eine
whatsapp gruppe auf mit 83 millionen
mitgliedern alle dabei da schreibt dann
sabine hey leute bin positiv krankes ihm
war am wochenende bei oma hilde
geburtstag darauf norbert loch auf ich
auch und kerstin so erich auch soll aber
wie geht es denn opa keine ahnung die
geht nicht mehr ans telefon trauriges
energy und das beste ist meine damen und
herren mit dieser whatsapp gruppe hätten
wir auch direkt ein impf register der
kanzler ruft offiziell dazu auf seinen
impfstatus da freiwillig anzugeben und
dann heißt es sekunden später
1,4 millionen sachsen haben die gruppe
verlassen
sorry liebe sachsen aber der schale geld
musste einfach sein
[Musik]
kennen uns doch gar nicht große
diskussion diese woche auch als
sogenannte orientierungs debatte im
bundestag könnte die allgemeine
impfpflicht die impflücken schließen
kleiner spoiler meinerseits die kommt am
ende sowieso nicht und falls doch liebe
querdenker zu hause keine angst dieser
staat ist gar nicht in der lage sie
durchzusetzen oder zu kontrollieren
wegen fehlender digitalisierung der
digitalen patientenakte arbeiten wir
seit 2003 ist immer noch nicht da und
natürlich wegen total überlastet
verwaltung es wäre nicht zu
kontrollieren zumal die ampel ja immer
noch keinen eigenen gesetzentwurf zur
pflicht vorlegt damit niemand merkt wie
zerstritten die bei dem thema sind dafür
wagt olaf scholz aber immer wieder sehr
optimistischen prognosen von den 80
prozent mindestens erst kämpften die er
bis ende januar prophezeit hat sind wir
meilenweit entfernt es wirkt erstaunlich
wie weit der olaf mit seinen vorhersagen
daneben haut
jetzt neu bei astrotv schulz adamus der
kanzlerwahl und deshalb ist es gut dass
wir unser ziel dass wir zuletzt gesetzt
hatten bis weihnachten 30 millionen
impfungen zu erreichen auch tatsächlich
erreicht haben haben wir nicht wir haben
einfach den start termin vorverlegt wir
wollen aber noch besser werden bis ende
januar wollen wir noch einmal 30
millionen impfung schaffen nein schaffen
wir nicht es wird bis zu zehn millionen
impfungen pro woche geben und dass das
jetzt gut vorbereitet wird dafür habe
ich gesagt es hat natürlich nie zehn
millionen impfungen pro woche gegeben
wir brechen auf in eine neue zeit eine
zeit gut wird nein wird sie nicht
stolzer da muss der schlechteste
wahrsager der welt
saugen titeln was liegt dass ich noch
einmal so unnötig konkret fest diese
woche musste scholz adamus erstmals
seinen gesundheitsminister öffentlich
verteidigen bei der bund länder runde am
montag war karl lauterbach nämlich der
watsch'n august vom dienst
ministerpräsidenten wie volker bouffier
hier sind stinksauer weil karl sie mit
der verkürzung des genesenen status
total überrumpelt hat ja es gab
deutliche kritik an gesundheitsminister
lauterbach lauterbach der hat einige
verärgert seinen ordentlichen rüffel
eingefangen also das ist nicht gut
angekommen das geht so nicht waren
schüsse an gesundheitsminister
lauterbach holterdiepolter er wurde
verpflichtet künftig solche änderungen
nur mit vorlauf umzusetzen ich war
ja nicht unverdienter rüffel man kann
sich nicht für jede politische
entscheidung hinter der wissenschaft
verstecken in der schweiz ist man zum
beispiel aktuell immer noch zwölf monate
gewesen corona maßnahmen dass das
mindeste müssen verständlich ungerecht
sein und das hat zuletzt leider gar
nicht gut geklappt herzlich willkommen
zur neuen show von tina hausten und
christian ehring
die 5000 beklopptesten corona maßnahmen
die inzwischen auch die gut billigsten
bürger die sonst echt alles mittragen so
langsam aber doch ein bisschen sauer
machen weil irgendwann ist ja auch mal
gut
hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe
zuschauer
was braucht ein corona müdes land kurz
vor dem kollektiven nervenzusammenbruch
genau
überraschungen die leute lieben
überraschungen oder christian ja ich zum
beispiel bin ich aufgewacht und hatte
über nacht überraschend meinen genießen
einen status verloren habe ich wirklich
gut
genesen den status einfach mal so von
sechs auf drei monate verkürzt ohne
ankündigung die betroffenen mussten sich
das tagelang selber zusammen googeln
denn karl lauterbach hat es uns erst
tage später erklärt und zwar nicht im
bundestag nein das kann ja jeder sondern
pakets markus lanz war und besser als im
dschungelcamp würde ich sagen und war
jedes fucking bundesland diese genesenen
regel auch noch völlig anders umsetzt
kann es gut sein dass ich in berlin als
genesener in einem ic steige und dann
sechs stunden und eine überteuerte
gulaschsuppe später steige ich in
münchen als total ungeimpfter looser
wieder aus
[Musik]
leute nicht immer nur meckern
handwerklich kann man das doch
regelrecht bewundern wie bund und länder
hier wirklich maximale verwirrung
stiften also ausnahmen gelten für
dreifach geimpfte sprich gewusst hatte
für genesene und doppelt geimpfte
doppelt geimpfte und genesene frisch
doppelt geimpfte der maximal drei monate
ab dem tag der zweitimpfung frisch
genesene maximal drei monate nach dem
tag des positiven pcr tests und genießen
und frisch einmal geimpft die dürfen
auch so in die restaurants so
textaufgabe zwei frisch geputzt hatte
und drei doppelt genesene gehen in ein
restaurant das einen zweifach
geschiedenen ungeimpften aus bielefeld
gehört und bestellen achtung fast
frische ausland frage wann hat christian
drosten geburtstag
ist in der geposteten mit johnson &
johnson geimpft weil dann dürfte der
dann allerdings ohne test gar nicht mehr
sitzen sehr gut aufgebaut
sehr gut denn auch völlig überraschend
eingeführten regeln gelten und zwar für
alle das hier ist immer noch ein
rechtsstaat während außerhalb des
parlaments der genesenen status über
nacht von sechs auf drei monate gekürzt
wurde gilt das für abgeordnete im
reichstagsgebäude nicht nein natürlich
nicht und zwar aus wissenschaftlichen
gründen denn der organismus von
politikern
funktioniert ja völlig anders als
unserer
es gibt neuerdings so viele wunderbar
bekloppte kroner maßnahmen beispiel
warum dürfen gemusterte vom ersten tag
an alles ohne test obwohl die spritzen
oder gar nicht wirkt ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß es nicht oder warum haben die
klubs in berlin zwar noch aus haben wir
das nicht mehr tanzen
wie wollen sie das ganze kontrollieren
ab wann beginnt denn eigentlich tanzen
ja das ist halt genau die frage wir
haben versucht zu herauszufinden was
tanzen bedeutet
ist das hier schon tanzen
[Musik]
die 5000 beklopptesten corona maßnahmen
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher